I think a lot of people when they think
about I show that Greg Daniels is making
a probably thinking about something
that's gonna be like hilarious and yes
there's gonna be a lot of laughs in this
show but it's so thoughtful and I want
to know from you guys what you think
sort of the balance will be between
people laughing out loud and maybe
taking time out after they finish an
episode to honestly ponder the questions
that the show presents to them and one
of the things that I think is so
interesting is problems that are in
society today are also in Lakeview in
this digital afterlife and his reasoning
behind that was well if this is a
digital afterlife created by people and
it's going to have a lot of the same
problems in the world that they live in
hello in Athens 10 fingers and toes
pretty seamless this is the first day of
the rest of your afterlife I feel like
this show it's such a conversation
starter and because it does pose a lot
of questions
well everybody will laugh along and and
we get these really funny moments there
are other moments where you go wow
that's kind of messed up and that's kind
of how it might be real cutie so I
understand you're in a bad place
yesterday it's only weird if you make it
weird it has a bit of everything so it's
got the mystery it's a romantic comedy
it's got sci-fi and it's what was it a
genre stew and mixing and all these
things that I think there's something in
there for everyone there's a guy named
Lincoln to do he's in computers you know
you can walk on water whenever
no way the situation that we're all in
right now
I think it's putting everything into a
different perspective especially when it
comes to the content that we are
consuming and when I'm watching this
show I can't help but draw a parallel
between what Nathan is in in the
situation that he kind of can't get out
of he's stuck there and what we're all
in right now you know the biggest
comparisons right now will be what we're
doing right now
you know everybody's talking to
everybody over FaceTime and zoom and
Skype because you know most people are
self isolating hopefully you have the
luxury to be able to do that I know a
lot of people have to continue you know
working in essential jobs and my hat
goes off to them and and my thanks to
everybody that's doing that I mean
obviously there are so many more
important things going on in the world
than our show right now but we do hope
that you know when people watch it
they'll have a little bit of a skate
even though there are relatable topics
in the show you know at the end of the
day it's a comedy and we want people to
laugh and and kind of forget about their
troubles for a half hour here or an hour
there